With six days left to the election,
it's incredible how little public
discourse this past year has had do with
the actual issues.
Immigration has become a meme fest
revolving around trump's proposed wall.
Abortion was basically relegated to one
three minute exchange in the final
debate.
There's been virtually nothing on
legalizing marijuana,
the war on drugs or reforming our prison
system.
Foreign policy has been reduced to trump
saying he can't tell us what he's going
to do so that he doesn't tip anyone off
versus Hillary promoting her experience,
much of which was a disaster.
There's been pretty much no talk of
infrastructure or education,
but a whole lot on genital grabbing and
hacked emails.
My hope is that this is the last
election will ever have were seemingly
every major issue is neglected,
and the minute he said she said,
get center stage.
Out of all of this anger and frustration
in general lunacy.
I really do believe that something good
will rise from the ashes.
The majority of us want to talk about
the real issues.
We don't want to demonize everyone.
We don't want to be pandered to and we
do want to find solutions.
We got in this political mess this year
because for so long we've allowed the
system to let the lowest common
denominator rise to the top.
Maybe we needed this freak show to
happen so that the masses,
the silent majority,
would finally wake up and realize that
it's actually our lives,
our welfare,
and our families on the line.
Every generation has something new to
fight for and maybe for this generation,
the fight will be to recreate a system
by the people and for the people.
That's why the next few years are going
to be an incredibly important piece of
history where we sit back and let the
worst of us continue to take control or
will we fight back?
Will we find allies where we used to
find enemies and what we stand for
principles even when it's not popular to
do so.
I really believe that will do the right
thing,
but the only way we'll do it is by
really discussing issues and not the
side show.
Let's demand that our leaders explain
why they believe in what they believe,
why they vote,
the way they vote,
and why they deserve the right to speak
for us as citizens.
Let's step back from the scandals and
the screaming and focus on education and
empowerment.
Politicians in the media aren't going to
magically just become better.
We have to demand that they do and the
only way that we can demand it is if we
demand it from ourselves.
We can start by being outspoken instead
of just outraged.
This week we're continuing our
collaboration with learn liberty.
We're teaming up with learn liberty once
a month to talk to professors,
thought leaders and authors on a wide
variety of topics all related to free
speech and classical liberalism to
things we could certainly use a little
more of these days.
Joining me this week is Dr Steve Davies.
Dr Davis is head of education at the
Institute of Economic Affairs in London.
He's also a lecturer and a historian
whose research includes crime and
criminal justice,
the history of ideas and political
thought,
comparative economic
history,
and much more.
In short,
this guy knows his stuff and we're going
to get into all of it or at least as
much as we can in an hour.
So sit back,
take a break from the sound bytes and
distractions and open your minds to the
issues that matter.
Your brain will thank you and your
country will too.
We're continuing our monthly
collaboration with my friends with learn
liberty.
This week my guest is head of education
at the Institute for Economic Affairs in
London as well as a historian and
lecturer and he flew all the way across
the pond to be here.
Dr Steve Davies.
Welcome to the show.
Thank you very much.
Glad to be here.
I heard you got held up by President
Obama,
so we did.
We just got told that a vip was going
through the airport and so they have
just shut it down for half an hour.
So we were held up.
I guess he must have been really
important.
Yeah.
After 11 and a half hour flight,
you don't even want to hear that it's
the president or there's nobody really
that.
Absolutely.
So.
All right.
There's so much that I want to do with
you and I watched a ton of your learn
liberty videos,
so I'm.
I'm pretty well versed in some of the
stuff that you're well versed in.
First,
did you want to come to America just one
more time before our election?
Well,
absolutely.
There's something really strange going
on here in the United States.
I think it's fair to say,
although maybe not that strange because
I actually think that what's happening
with Donald Trump is pulse for more
widespread phenomenon in most western
democracies,
which is the rise of a kind of politics.
It's commonly described,
I think misleadingly as right wing
populism and what it actually is is a
politics that combines left of center
economics,
strong support for the welfare state
with an extremely unpleasant kind of
nativism and she globalism and
nationalism,
and that's pretty much where Donald
Trump is coming from.
It's straightforward Hamiltonian
economic nationalism combined with a
very unpleasant kind of identity
politics,
I would say,
but he's not alone.
He's possibly much bigger phenomenon.
Okay,
so let's unpack a couple of those
phrases.
So you'd say this isn't a right wing
phenomenon because his politics are kind
of are kind of lame,
right?
Uh,
and that it's that,
but he is using nationalism so that,
that is more of the right side.
What,
what were the other parts that were the
source of support for the welfare state
support for the strictly national basis,
I mean,
the correct name for this kind of
politics I think is nationalist
collectivism.
You could call it national socialism,
but the kinds of being claimed already
that might be a little too scary,
too scary.
It's nationalist collectivism basically.
And it's on the rise across most Western
democracies.
Few exceptions like Spain,
Portugal,
Ireland,
but otherwise this is the kind of
politics that we see on the rise
everywhere.
I'm afraid Marine Le Pen in France get
builders in the Netherlands,
Donald Trump here pretty much
everywhere.
Canada is another exception.
So what is happening globally that has
caused that?
This isn't just a fun.
I mean I think everyone in America
thinks everything is about us all the
time and this is just our phenomenon.
It has nothing to do with anything else,
but what's happening?
Well,
there are two things.
I think one of them is that a lot of the
support for this kind of politics comes
from older working class voters in what
you would call the rust belt,
a decade x industrial areas where life
has not been good for quite a long time
and these people feel that they're
ignored by the political establishment,
that the system is not working in their
interests and that kicking back.
Yeah.
That's one reason.
And some of that you think you would
argue is legit,
right?
Yeah.
It's legitimate.
Dude,
they're quite right.
You know,
life has been pretty hard for them for
quite a long time.
The other thing though,
which I actually think is more important
is it's to do with the politics of
identity.
Uh,
it's to do with a feeling that a certain
kind of identity is under threat from
the process of globalization.
Cosmopolitanism,
maybe political correctness,
a whole bunch of stuff like that.
So there's a very powerful cultural
reaction,
a reassertion of a certain kind of
identity.
Uh,
and I think that is what is really
potent and really driving this kind of
politics.
So how much of that is just a reaction
to some of this stuff happening on the
left?
That's,
you know,
I,
I come from the left,
so that's the part that I've been
focusing on and I do see a certain
element of the rise of trump and the
political correctness stuff and you
know,
the social justice warrior stuff.
I see it as a natural reaction to what
has happened on the left or maybe maybe
in Europe.
It's more because of immigration that
these marine Le Pen for example,
et Cetera.
I think that there is an element of
truth in both of those things.
Actually.
Undoubtedly the push button issue,
uh,
as we saw in the brexit referendum in
the UK for example,
uh,
and with Marion Le Pen is immigration,
particularly immigration from the Middle
East,
but also from other parts of the world
as well.
But that's in a way is not so much
because of immigration per se.
It's because the way in which large
scale movement into people is seemed to
be transforming and changing the nature
of a settled and established a national
community.
And now I think that in terms of
particularly the United States,
yes,
there is quite a lot of pushback
against,
uh,
the kind of a social justice warrior as
you alluded to a pc politics on the left
and in particular the politics of
identity.
If you're going to push a politics of
identity where apparently the only group
who aren't allowed to have an identity
are white working class men.
Sooner or later those kinds of people
are going to say,
well,
hold on a minute.
You know,
I have this identity to which you are
not respecting your own terms.
So there's a lot of pushback coming on
and I think that shows how really the
response that liberals need to have,
and I would include many people on the
left in that category should be one way.
You were certainly importance of
individualism and the identity as being
something that to a great degree is
personally chosen and formed rather than
being something that's given to you.
And fixed in some way.
Yeah,
I mean I love that and that's exactly
how my own evolution has happened over
the last couple of years.
Coming out of progressivism,
which is more about the collective to
ultimately realize I would only want to
be judged by my own thoughts and my own
actions,
so let's circle back a little bit to to
Europe and then we'll do our elections.
Now we're getting some big stuff.
So when it comes to the immigration
situation all over Europe,
I sense what you're saying is there's a
certain natural reaction to people
coming in and not assimilating properly
or whatever else.
There may be the economic strains and
all that stuff.
What?
What is the proper solution for all
these countries now?
Because the cat's out of the bag
already,
right?
Well actually a lot of the responses
misguided in my view because for
example,
there was a widespread perception
feeling that immigration imposes costs
on the countries that the immigrants go
to.
All of the research I was actually.
This is not the case.
Immigrants are actually extremely good
news because typically they are younger
than the host population.
They are almost always in work.
They come to look for work,
they want to do productive labor,
how can that be a problem you might say,
and so typically they are tax payers
rather than tax consumers.
They typically make a net contribution
to the budget.
They do not depress wages because
typically they do work that the
indigenous population either can't or
won't do usually because they lack the
skillset.
They do have a marginal depressing
effect on the wages of the bottom 10
percent of the income range,
but that's about it,
but there's a widespread misconception
or misunderstanding of what the
economics of immigration is actually a
balance and that's a failure of public
education really.
So that's part of it.
I think the more profound thing though
is a feeling that there's a threat to an
established indigenous culture and I
think the response here is to simply be
more confident.
I have enormous confidence in the
Assembler to power of the culture of a
free society and I think the thing to do
is not to say,
okay,
here are people who are asserting a
particular collective cultural identity.
What we need to do is assert our own one
in response to that and aggressively
against that verse one,
the thing to do is to emphasize
individualism and the degree to which
are modern free society is one where
people are free to form that shape their
own identity through the choices that
they make and that should be true for
everybody.
Right?
So in a way you're.
You're looking at it in sort of the
macro sense of are we should deal with
all this a certain amount of the people
on the ground,
they just don't see it that way because
they see where you are.
These people coming in,
even if the job thing is incorrect,
they feel that their jobs are being
taken.
So when I,
when I read stories about things like in
Germany that I saw something that it was
going to cost one point 4 billion euros
to give the refugees or the migrants
dental care,
I mean these things are just not true.
Basically
that isn't true.
If you look at the areas where there are
problems,
these are all areas where it's the state
that is in boulder as a major provider.
You do not see grocery stores panicking
because they suddenly have to find food
products and other products for new
customers on the country.
They look at it as a business
opportunity.
The private sector everywhere actually
sees large scale movement of people as
being,
as I say,
an opportunity.
Not a problem.
It's the areas where the state is
involved that you find problems.
And what that shows us is actually the
incompetence inefficiency of modern
governments as compared to the private
sector.
So even if we viewed everyone as the,
as the individual that we're going to
talk a lot about the individual here,
um,
do you think there's possibly something
different with this wave of immigration
related to terrorism and we know that
there's a certain amount of people that
isis wants to infiltrate and cross
borders that there is something
different about this.
Because even if all of us in the west
say it's about individualism and let's
judge people individually and by their
actions and all those things.
If a certain amount of people don't want
to assimilate what,
what do you do then?
Well,
in in in one sense,
not assimilating is not in and of itself
a problem where I live in Manchester
then so well established Jewish
community,
been there since the 18,
eighties and nineties.
These people are Hacidic Jews,
very strict,
ultra orthodox.
A lot of them are lubavitch has
actually,
and they're not assimilated in some
sense.
It's totally never watched television,
for example,
against their beliefs and sold,
but nobody I think would regard that as
a problem.
From my point of view.
It just means I've got a wonderful
bakery in May,
was fantastic bagels,
right?
The problem is,
as you say,
the Association of a certain category of
migrants from the Middle East with
Islamic terrorism.
Now what's the best way to respond to
that?
That is a difficult issue on my own
view,
very much is that the.
The ultimate solution is to try and sort
out the complete mess at the Middle East
has become a,
but in the short term,
essentially this is a policing problem.
What you definitely don't want to think
about is dealing with this as a problem
of military security is essentially a
law enforcement problem.
Right?
So as someone that doesn't love state
power,
does it make you nervous that you have
to sort of give a certain amount of
state power to the police or to the
border controls or whatever to actually
make sure that they're doing the right
job?
Yes,
I am nervous about that.
And what I would say by the way is that
the kind of increase in state
surveillance which has been put through
in the United Kingdom,
for example,
by our current prime minister when she
was in a previous job as home secretary,
is actually counterproductive in that
regard because basically if you think
about the trust of the security services
of golf,
they're looking for the proverbial
needle in a haystack.
So if that's the case,
why do you then make the haystack even
bigger?
By intercepting virtually everybody's
email.
That actually makes our job more
difficult,
not easier.
And so I think that actually what really
you need is good old fashioned
undercover intelligence work,
which means penetrating organizations.
Identifying key people,
you basically try and keep an eye on and
good old fashioned spy work really.
It's always going to work,
but that's the way to do it.
It's interesting because you're making a
real argument for limited government and
the slim trim government through,
through a prism that a lot of people
don't think of it.
They think we need big government to
protect us from things and,
and have surveillance and all of these
things that people that are for it,
but you're really making an argument for
if you actually took a lot of that away,
might be a more efficient way of killing
me.
It will be much more effective in my
view.
Huh.
That's really interesting.
So let's,
let's talk about brexit a little bit
because I did a little bit of it on this
show and uh,
you know,
I'm constantly talking about how our
American media doesn't give us much of
anything.
So we didn't hear about it at all.
Then two days before everybody was
freaking out about it.
We saw it on twitter,
then it happened that we don't talk
about it again.
Yeah.
So for people that have no idea what
happened,
can you just give me a little history of
it and then,
and then where we're at now,
Britain's relationship with the European
Union has always been,
I think,
a bit fraught and difficult.
It's been like one of those unhappy
marriages,
if you will,
were outside just wonder why all those
two people together.
Uh,
the reason being that British
politicians on the British public ever
since we first joined the European
Economic Community,
sees that then was in 1973 have always
seen as being basically about economics.
It's all about getting economic
advantage on the constant after they'd
been equally clan right since the
Messina conference in 1954.
But this is all about building a
political union.
So they see it as part of the kind of
grand political project.
And the British politicians always say,
oh,
they don't really mean that these
continentals this is just rhetoric,
which of course is actually quite
offensive.
And not surprisingly,
the continentals get a bit irritated by
this attitude.
So essentially there's a growing
mismatch between what the British public
think the EU should be.
And the actual nature of that project,
and that's got significantly worse since
the Maastricht treaty,
so it caused all kinds of internal
political reactions and David Cameron in
what I have to say.
It was a grotesque act of misjudgment
from his own perspective called a
referendum to try and sort out his
internal politics.
And now in that referendum,
everyone thought the expectation was
that the status quo would win.
I must say I expected that.
So that's basically why he called it
because he was empowering,
figured out,
call it,
they'll agree with me and that'll sort
out my party problem.
That's because generally speaking,
referenda normally go for the status
quo.
And in this case,
the overwhelming majority of members of
parliament,
most of the respected pundits,
most economists,
virtually all of the big business firms
that were asked the Bank of England,
pretty much any authority figure you
care to mention said,
yes,
you need to vote remain.
So what took place was a popular
insurgency and in which the ordinary
British public thought,
well,
no,
we don't agree with this.
And they basically went against the
advice of the bulk of the political
media business leadership.
Now the vote that came together to a
vote leave,
if you will,
was basically a coalition of three quite
distinct groups.
I think on the one hand you had what you
might call Brexit Shyer.
A older conservative voters,
typically a middleclass,
slightly older,
living in the countryside,
living in the affluent suburbs,
and that's one block.
So that's a little bit of the people
that you described voting for trump.
It's a little bit,
slightly more moderate.
The second group,
however,
Arlette people who voted for trump,
this is older white working class voters
in the traditional labour heartlands of
the northeast of England,
the Midlands,
Yorkshire,
the voting,
some constituencies that like
Sunderland,
which is our current of say scratch and
Wilkes Barre.
That was a 69 percent vote for leave,
an absolute landslide.
And that was,
it was that block of what you might call
a populist voters working class that put
leave over.
The third very small group,
which I belong to,
is what you might call radical classical
liberals who are very small group.
But again,
you could say we made the difference in
some ways because what we wanted to us
to be able to have a greater range of
options for the British government by
being outside of the year,
use controls and constraints.
So there's those three blocks of people
that voted for leave basically.
Yeah.
I like radical classical liberals
because I've been saying classical
liberals.
It sounds too to benign or something.
Radical has a little something extra
there.
So.
Okay.
So when it was happening and you,
you say you were part of this,
uh,
did you expect the vote to go that way?
Because as you're saying,
the entire establishment was saying,
don't do it.
It's not going to happen.
The polls were showing it wasn't going
to happen.
No,
I always thought it was going to be
tight.
But my own expectation was that it was
going to be about 51 percent remained to
49 percent leave because normally in
referenda like this,
the undecided voters who make up their
mind at the last minute split to two,
one for the status quo.
Now,
I actually think they did here.
But what happened was that the polls d
underestimated the leaves share of the
vote by about five percent.
The reason being a lot of the people who
voted leave are people who did not
normally vote,
and pollsters always discount people who
say that they don't vote,
so they got their sampling wrong,
and so they underestimated the,
the,
the share of the vote that leaves going
to get.
So looping this back to trump,
because I see such parallels here,
I suspect the exact same thing is gonna
happen.
I'm not saying trump's going gonna win,
but I do suspect there a depression in
the polls because a certain amount of
his supporters now either aren't being
pulled for whatever they're in places
that they're not polling or they don't
want.
They don't want to be publicly shamed or
admitted or something like that.
So I sent that.
What you're talking about here,
this groundswell of support that was not
spoken of,
I,
I suspect that's happening right now.
Do you think that's fair?
Right?
Do think so?
I think there's two things going on
there.
One is what century here in Los Angeles
needs is known as the Tom Bradley,
if people are not honest in the answers
that gives the pollsters,
uh,
but also I think that actually the
pollsters samples are probably slightly
wrong.
They're probably a,
not counting the correct number of trump
voters because one of the things he did
during the primaries was to bring a
record number of people into the primary
process who had never voted before.
Now,
what I suspect that means is he's going
to be much more competitive than it
currently appears to be in states like
Ohio,
Pennsylvania,
uh,
maybe even Michigan and Arizona where I
think there's a significant number of
people who have not voted before who
will vote.
Yeah.
What do you make of when you see Nigel
farrage come here and speak at trump
rallies?
W,
what do you make of the connection
between the two of them?
And,
and is this really,
you know,
if when I click on info wars,
a link or some of the other things,
the more right things,
Breitbart,
that really they're fighting the
globalists,
the globalists are coming here.
I think there's some degree to a one
world government thing that's trying to
formulate,
but like how much it feels so
conspiratorial.
Well,
I that that's exactly the kind of
alignment that I was talking about these
books,
but Nigel farage and Ukip in the UK,
Donald trump hair,
that part of the nationalist reaction
against the increased cosmopolitanism
globalization that we've seen in the
last 20 to 30 years.
Uh,
there's a feeling that this
transnational organizations that are
pushing an agenda they don't like,
but basically it's more a kind of
localism or hostility to cosmopolitanism
and to globalism.
And you see that on both sides of the
Atlantic.
Now.
That's a politics I strongly reject.
But you can't deny the reality of the
existence of it.
Yeah.
And that's what makes it so hard to talk
about because it's not fun to talk about
something you reject,
but no,
to be honest,
to be a classical liberal,
you have to acknowledge that something's
happening,
which is it's no point in ignoring this.
Maybe if you disagree with something,
with a belief that a lot of people have,
the thing to do is to engage with it
when you have to do is to actually talk
to these people,
respect their views,
but show them that you think they are
mistaken and here's why that mistake.
Yeah.
Okay,
so now brexit happens.
Yeah.
Everyone said the next day the markets
are going to crash,
the economy is going to crash,
everything will be over.
We're going to be fighting for bread or
have you had red light?
No,
no,
no problem.
The.
I think we're still the funding goal
stage right now.
I think this going to be an enormous and
quite serious political route with the
United Kingdom the next few months.
The big question that was,
okay,
what do we do?
And there are really two routes that the
British government can take quite simply
to simplify it.
One is they can go for what's a
membership of what's called the European
economic area,
which means that we would be a bit like
Norway.
Now.
That means we would have access to the
European single market regime,
but we will still be bound by lots of EU
regulations while no longer having any
say in how,
what they were or how they were formed.
So that's sort,
sorta like,
that's sort of like staying in the EU
but light.
Exactly,
exactly.
And the,
um,
uh,
the thing,
the other alternative is to say,
well,
we don't want to do that.
We basically wanted negotiate a free
trade deal with the Aau.
The trouble is that wants to resume my
triggers,
what's called article 50 of the Lisbon
Treaty,
which is the withdrawal process.
It's got a strict two year limit and
it's not clear that you can negotiate a
two year,
a free trade deal in just two years.
So that would throw us back a pot just
membership of the World Trade
Organization,
which means that will then be a six and
a half percent tarriff between Britain
and Europe.
Now,
that's probably more than compensated
for by the decline in the value of the
pound that's taken place,
but it's still not,
not very welcome.
Now the the critical political thing is
the city of London,
a seven percent of British GDP would
lose its passporting rights.
It would not be able to do euro
denominated business unless we're in the
European economic area.
The problem politically for Theresa May
and the government is that the Europeans
have been very reasonably in what you're
saying,
look,
if you become member of the EA,
you have to accept free movement of
Labor.
That's part of the deal.
You don't cherry pick your conditions,
which seems perfectly reasonable to me,
and the problem is that for political
reasons,
because so many of the people who voted
leave did so on anti immigration
grounds.
She is not all of them,
but a significant portion of them.
Sure she's not prepared to do that,
and so the result is that they have,
it looks like we're going to actually
not applied to join the eea effectively
and that's going to cause enormous
political ructions.
Now in the longer term,
I think the British economy will do
fine.
There may be some,
some will be some losers,
probably the city of London.
There'll be some gangers though,
a manufacturers in particular,
an export as consumers because the price
of goods like food will go down,
it'll even out it's a bit of a wash
ready,
but in the short term is going to be
quite a lot of political fireworks,
so all that being said aren't those
subtle reasons that brexit was actually
the right decision because you guys
still have to sort of negotiate things
with the EU in a weird way that allow
them to have power over you and that was
what the whole purpose of leading way.
So in a way it's like better to do it
now than 10 years when a lot of this
stuff has even been tight.
Absolutely.
I mean the point is what brexit does,
and this was my main reason for voting
for.
I wasn't passionate lever,
but I did vote leave the end.
The main reasons for doing it is that it
increases the range of political
possibilities open to the British
electorate and the British government
for both good and bad.
Right now they're highly constrained
because a whole lot of radical policies
on both left and right would fall foul
of the EU zone rules and regulations,
so there's actually a very narrow range
of what is allowable politically now
that we have left the a year or once
we've left a year ago.
It becomes much wider.
Whole range of options are opened up
now.
The job for me then is to argue for the
right wants to be really bad ones.
Your,
your,
your job just started.
Exactly.
Yes.
But that's,
so that's my main reason for doing it
and I think there are much greater
options open to us now in the future.
Yeah.
Do you sense that the EU as a,
as a entity is really in trouble?
I mean,
everything beyond what just happened
with,
with you guys.
I mean they've got grease basically in a
hostage situation,
right?
I mean is that,
am I being too?
No.
Greeks would agree with.
Yeah.
I mean,
so what do you think the future here is
you have,
you know,
Britain leaving,
you've got grease in a hostage
situation.
I mean,
ultimately the borders that are
crumbling people aren't happy with.
Well,
the real problem that the EU faces is
the incredible act of Hubris they did at
the master treaty,
which is to create a single currency
when they don't have a single
government.
Now,
interestingly,
pretty much every economist on the
planet at the time,
regardless of their politics,
said that this was a really bad idea and
they all thought it was a bad idea for
the same reason,
which is that there's no historical case
ever have a single currency area that
doesn't have a single government
surviving,
and if you do have a single currency
area in countries that are not
economically aligned,
if you will,
and you don't have a single government,
all kinds of really bad stuff happens.
Paul trible and Milton Friedman in the
same way,
made almost exactly the same point that
they ignore the advice from all the
economists as portraying when rather
which Lee put it.
A.
The good news is we know now the optimal
currency area theory is completely
correct.
The bad news is we've had to bugger up
the economy of a continent to figure it
out,
figure it out,
approve it,
so the point is they.
They still haven't resolved that
problem.
Now,
Greece is a small country.
They can handle Greece.
What if Italy goes under,
which is quite likely the Italian
banking system is in really,
really bad shape.
If there's a major crisis in Italy or
maybe in France or some other larger
country,
they won't be able to resolve it,
so they're going to have to either
create something like a government for
the euro zone or they're going to have
to allow the euro to be dismantled and
either of those as a huge event.
Plus there's an election next spring in
France and there's a pretty reasonable
chance that marine Le Pen will win the
election.
If she's up against one candidate from a
center,
right Alan page,
she will lose if she's up against the
former president,
Sarkozy,
the polls show,
it's very,
very close and I would actually take her
to beat him,
right?
Because that could be one of the
situations where the Poles are going to
hate her.
Plus also these polls now before
campaign,
she's a very effective campaigner and so
I think she could beat their rival
candidate if it's Sarkozy.
Now,
if she became president mean the odds
are still against that.
But if she did,
she said she'd immediately call a
referendum on France leaving the EU.
Now all the Poles there indicates 65
percent of the French public would vote
leave.
Now if that happens,
the Aau is finished.
That's it.
It's done full.
So it's in really bad.
It's an a very tricky situation right
now.
The EU.
So for someone like yourself,
again,
classical liberal,
and you want this to be about the
individuals.
So I can understand the separation.
Why you think ultimately this is good.
It seems like in a weird way,
you then have to align yourself with the
Marie Le Pen's,
with the,
uh,
you know,
you end up by default falling into a
category with the people that want to
leave the event with the nationalist
street.
But it,
but I don't sense that you have.
So how does that,
how do you negotiate that with yourself,
with great difficulty?
This is the big problem.
The problem for many classical liberals
in the UK was if we vote leave,
will this not give a big boost to
precisely the kind of politics that you
most dislike?
That was the argument desert.
My colleagues for example.
Uh,
I think that,
uh,
basically you have to realize if things
like this happen,
you are going to be alongside a bunch of
people that otherwise you totally
detest.
And what you then have to do is to argue
the case very,
very strongly against them.
Now the crucial thing here I think is
for liberals both left and right of you,
well classical liberals and social
liberals to come together and to realize
that they have a common photos,
if you will,
in the shape of the national
collectivists.
And on the other hand,
the radical radical left.
And so here in the United States for
example,
I think it's quite likely that there may
well be a kind of a proximal in the next
few years between the kind of moderate
part of the Republican Party.
So called,
which is actually many ways the more
libertarian part,
fiscally conservative,
but socially liberal you will,
and on the other hand,
the mainstream of the Democrats,
uh,
and this will be aimed at both the kind
of people who are now voting for trump
and also the kind of people who were
supporting Bernie Sanders earlier on.
Okay.
The primary.
So I know this is this political
realignment is one of the things you've
been talking about lately.
And I love that because that's exactly
what I've been trying to talk about,
that I no longer as a,
as a classical liberal,
I don't really see conservatives as my
enemy as maybe five years ago I might
have thought that they would be where
now it's like,
yeah,
we can have some disagreements about
taxes and maybe we're not in the exact
place related to abortion or a series of
states rights or whatever,
but there has to be a new center
developing here.
Otherwise a lot of classical liberals
will end up going this,
you know,
the Libertarians will end up going
further to the right.
Classical liberals may go further left
and that that's not good for.
Yeah,
well indeed.
The way to think of is this,
I think since about the 19 seventies,
the big argument in politics on both
sides of the Atlantic,
but particularly here in the US has been
between one group of people who are
economically interventionists in the
gala Cesarean,
but socially liberal versus another
group who appropriate market,
but socially and culturally
conservative.
That's been the big division.
What I think we're now moving towards
this is a situation where they divide is
between one group of people who are
broadly free market,
broadly individualists,
globalist,
perhaps a bit more egalitarian than the
classical liberals would like,
but broadly liberal versus another group
which is the national collective.
It's I mentioned earlier who are
actually economically interventionists,
pro welfare state,
but very culturally conservative,
quite authoritarian,
anti globalist,
a anti cosmopolitan,
and that's the new division I think
we're seeing in politics everywhere and
what that means is that all a lot of the
existing subgroups are going to split
up,
so conservatives are going to have to
decide,
well,
okay,
what is more important to you?
The cultural conservatism and the
nationalism or the free markets and the
individualism and if you're on the left
you have to decide,
well,
okay,
what am I really more interested in a.
and if you're one of the kind of
identity Marion anti globalist left,
you actually may find yourself thinking,
well actually right now I've got.
I've probably got more in common in some
ways with this kind of new emerging
Hamiltonian nationalist politics.
If on the other hand you really value
individual liberty and globalism,
openness to the rest of the world,
then you're going to find yourself
making alliances with these other people
who were forming your opponent.
So I think this is kind of big shuffling
of the deck going on in most Western
democracies.
So as a historian,
what can you think of another time where
we had such a,
maybe not on a global scale because
we're so connected now,
but where you saw just these real
fractures happening in real time.
Like when's the last time you saw
something?
Well,
the last time it happened in the UK,
certainly it was in the 19 sixties in
1970 and I think something like that
happened over here in the United States
as well,
where you had this sudden reversal where
the south went from being solidly
democratic where you know if you found
two Republican votes that countered it
must have voted twice to the situation
we have now where the south is solidly
Republican and Democrats will become the
party of the north entirely.
That kind of switched took place then in
the sixties and seventies.
Similarly in the UK,
back in the eighties and nineties here
in the United States with William
Jennings Bryan,
the cross of and the famous Democratic
convention in Nineteen Ninety six when
the populous basically took over the
Democratic Party,
major change in the nature of the
Democratic Party landslide victory.
Republicans again,
big realignment of votes and interest in
the states.
Then so this kind of thing has happened
before.
It's not unprecedented,
but what do you add about the global
element where now it's like we're so
connected.
We're all on twitter.
We're all watching TV and on the
Internet and that these things are
happening at once and that were 100
years ago.
If something happened across the pond,
it mattered,
but we didn't know about it for awhile
versus now.
It's all happening in real time.
This is true.
I mean there were more connections in
you might imagine in the 19th century,
but as you rightly say,
the much slower,
so now there is much more global
phenomenon.
In fact,
what is interesting is that very few
countries where this kind of realignment
isn't happening.
Canada is one not happen.
That sofa a Spain is another Japan,
but generally speaking you can see the
same thing happening everywhere and I
think what happens is that what now
because we're so interconnected,
what happens in one part of the world
tends to feed into what's happening
elsewhere.
Hence the great interest that Donald
trump and his supporters have shown in
Brexit and Nigel farage coming over here
and making all these talks.
That would not have happened 100 years
ago because I don't think that would've.
I don't think that would have happened
10 years ago when I saw Nigel farrage
out there at this rally.
I thought this is really unprecedented.
When is the last time that a,
that a leader from another country,
even in a,
you know,
an ally,
whatever it is,
it doesn't matter.
Came and with supporting the opposition
and presidential candidate.
I thought this is.
They probably is true.
It's a function of note cheaper and
travel and things like twitter and the
Internet.
Yeah.
Um.
Alright.
So let's shift a little bit from the
politics of the data is sort of the
broader stuff you describe yourself as a
classical.
Yes.
Yeah,
correct.
So now what is the difference so that I
can explain it to my people properly
when they say,
Dave,
you've become a libertarian.
How would you describe the difference
between a classical liberal,
liberal and a libertarian?
I don't think there is really such a
difference.
The word Libertarian,
strictly speaking means an analyst.
It was originally used to describe
communist standard kits.
So the,
he took her Pumpkin Bronte.
The problem here in the United States is
the good word liberal has been hijacked
by Social Democrats and so unlike the
European continent where liberal still
means a believer in private property,
limited government,
little government intervention,
individual liberty,
pluralism,
a,
it's now in the United States come to
mean something slightly different.
So the word libertarian came to be used
here in the United States to mean
basically what everyone else would be
called a classical liberal or a liberal
full stop.
So I don't think there is that much
difference.
There is perhaps a slight difference
emerging now in as much as increasingly
the word libertarian does mean something
more radical,
a bit more extreme.
So if you say you're a libertarian,
you probably imply that you're either an
anarchist already close to it.
If you say you're a classical liberal,
you imply that well you'll,
you know,
you'll not advocates.
You do think there was a necessity for
government.
So you're slightly more moderate.
So I think that's what it's like.
So I.
So I like that distinction because
that's definitely where I fall.
I think there is some use of the state
and then as I said,
I watched the Libertarian party,
you know,
their convention and it was like they're
screaming about,
you know,
a driver's licenses and it's like,
guys,
you're really missing the ball here,
you know,
like if we can't just let that go
because there were not going to.
Even if you're 100 percent right,
there's no way to really deep construct
an entire system like this.
Is there.
Like even if even if the libertarians
were purely purely right,
is there a way to actually take a
functioning somewhat functioning society
and really well the whole thing through
the political process.
No burning down,
but yes.
But no.
Well No,
the wage,
if you won't do on change science in the
longer run,
the thing to do is to do with the
grassroots level to create alternatives
to governments,
which I think is.
Well you shouldn't be doing.
Uh,
but I think with the kind of policy
you're describing is rampantly
self-indulgent.
I would say this is the kind of politics
of a certain kind of person who is
interested in being more pure than
everybody else.
Yeah.
Having an identity that is not
compromising completely pure.
It's the same kind of mentality that
leads people to become religious
fundamentalists of one variety or
another.
Uh,
it's a desire to be the person in the
group who is right when everybody else
is wrong,
and so the more of the people moved to
yours,
your position,
the more you're going to insist upon
these really extreme peculiar things
that still make you distinct.
So I'm afraid I'm not at all
sympathetic.
Right?
I mean it just seems like a nonstarter
when they're screaming about legalizing
heroin,
which we could talk about the war on
drugs,
which you talked about a lot and I'd be
happy to do that,
but when they're going there to start
and drivers licenses to start,
it's like,
guys,
this is not where it is.
Go for issues where you can persuade a
significant part of the public to come
to your position.
That's what politics is about.
Politics.
It's all about striking a pose and
trying to show how morally pure you all.
That's just pure virtue signaling.
I say self indulgent nonsense.
What do you want to do is make clear
what your ultimate position is,
but then say,
well,
okay,
on you go for issues where you can
persuade the significant part of the
broad public that you are right on that
yours is the way to go for and that's
where you go from mainstream issue is
not a fringe.
Issues like that,
which may be interesting for small
number of people,
but then there's a fun discussion to be
had I suppose about that stuff,
but not really a broader comes limiting.
Um,
all right,
so how do you decide how much state
power is?
Okay?
How do you make that distinction between
pure anarchy and I want something to
keep the wheels on here.
I think state powers,
that's part of what it is,
but it's not really just that.
The real distinction is between what
parts of your life do you want to be
driven by individual choice or choices
made my voluntary collectives versus
what parts of your life do you want to
be determined through some kind of
collective decision making process
through politics.
It'd be like your governance and I think
the answer that if you're a classical
liberal you would give is that you want
to maximize the scope of individual
decision making because that means
greater scope for individual discovery
and the also means that most people are,
you would argue the best judges of their
own interests,
so if you allow people to follow their
own judgment is what their interests are
collectively,
you'll end up with the best outcome that
maximizes human welfare so that that
leaves though certain number of areas
where there may be structural problems.
It's very difficult to act collectively
in these areas.
If you want to use a technical economic
terms,
maybe there's a public good aspect to
what you're talking about.
National Defense and in these areas,
it probably does pay to do things
through a collective decision making
process.
There's something about these core areas
that means that they are so important
that they have to be on universally.
You can't have a situation where say 90
percent are covered by the law
enforcement system and 10 percent or
not,
uh,
that would have all kinds of major
negative effects for the 90 percent who
were covered,
nevermind the 10 percent who,
who weren't.
And so there's a kind of limited range
of areas where,
yes,
you do definitely need the government.
Now I know there are people who will
say,
oh no,
no,
you know,
you could,
in theory,
yes you can do with that government,
but my own view is that,
well,
if that's the case,
why isn't everyone going to Somalia?
I know people say Somalia is better off
than some of its neighbors.
And it's true that if the choice is
anarchy or Pol Pot,
you will go for anarchy.
But that doesn't mean that necessarily a
stateless state of affairs is your first
choice.
Right?
So for all the people that would say,
well,
you know,
for the,
for the pure libertarian or whatever you
want to call them at this point,
that would say no,
remove the social safety net altogether.
Don't,
don't help the poorest under any
circumstances because if the government
gets out,
then private entities and private people
will fully fill that void.
I suspect that's not.
You don't believe that that.
Well,
no,
the thing is I would ideally like to see
a situation where you don't have the
government providing that function,
but the trouble is how'd you get from
here to there?
Yeah.
And the difficulty is that if you do
simply withdraw government safety net
provision,
this fundamental social welfare
transfers,
it's going to take a long time probably
before you get something that takes its
place.
And in the meantime,
a lot of people are going to suffer
quite severely.
And I don't think that's acceptable
quite honestly.
So the argument should be that,
uh,
you should a through private action
develop nonstate forms of welfare.
We should revive mutualism,
friendly societies,
fraternal orders,
all the great institutions that we used
to have,
which delivered a huge range of welfare
functions very,
very effectively,
particularly here in the United States,
so we should be looking to do that
privately revived flat,
but at the same time,
but we got rid of those as the state.
Well,
what happens as the state groups,
the plus also though it was due to quite
concrete legislative measures,
particularly ones urged by the medical
profession which were designed to drive,
um,
friendly societies out of healthcare
provision to what was called lodge
practice.
That that was a purely legislative
function also crowding out by the state.
It was just a lobby group.
The doctors got legislatures to pass
laws which made it very,
very difficult for a private volunteer
operation.
But the other thing you need to do,
I'm done by two original point,
is to say that,
well,
yes,
there is probably going to be a kind of
bottom level,
a provision provided by government
through the political process to ensure
that nobody falls below a certain
minimum level.
That nobody's starving the street.
People do have a minimal amount of,
uh,
resources,
so that they can actually survive.
Now,
what you can then do is get into
hydrostatic log about what the best way
of doing this is and certainly the way
we're doing it now in many western
countries is not the best way of doing
it,
but that's a minor argument.
The major principle I think is you do
concede if,
if,
if you're in my position that there
should be some kind of residual state
function of that salt.
Singapore probably has the best way of
doing it,
I would say amongst which is why well,
they have a system of forced savings
where essentially you are obliged to pay
money into a series of accounts,
one of which covers your healthcare
costs mainly in old age,
one of which gives you a pension.
Another one gives you protection against
sickness or unemployment.
Now the crucial difference between that
and the system we have is that the
accounts have your name on it,
so it's your money and you make these
for savings into these accounts,
right?
Your working life,
you've drawn them when you need them and
if you die,
that's a,
you know,
you fall under the proverbial bus,
all the money you paid in it becomes
part of your estate and goes to your
heirs.
That's incredible.
Now that's a much better system than the
one we have here.
That's incredible.
So it doesn't just get pulled into
something else and it's your property.
If you die,
let's say you have a large mountain,
you'll be happy with this.
I'm not sure what that is.
Very effective.
You've got a large amount in your health
savings account to cover the really
expensive part of healthcare which is
looking after you in the last six months
of your life.
But let's say you,
you die suddenly from a heart attack.
You don't like that,
that you weren't drawn in that fund and
it's there for your heirs.
It's part of your estate.
I mean,
I'm completely for that.
I,
I suspect that the left,
you know,
they would say,
well no,
the state should be able to take that.
Now you're gone and,
and give it to somebody else.
Well,
maybe,
but I mean the point is I think that's.
I would argue against that for a whole
number of reasons,
but I think that that's a much better
system and saying that's the system they
have in Singapore,
which is what do they do for the people
that are outside of the system that
really,
really poor the government actually
makes contributions on your behalf.
But Singapore is such a successful
economy and society that very,
very few people are on such low incomes
that they can't make some contribution
and the ones who have very low incomes
to say either the state's contribution
is entirely the minimal level or at tops
them up.
But that's actually a very marginal,
very small number of people.
And so if we wanted to change to a
system that was a little more like that,
and we've already hit on this a couple
times about how incremental change is
tough,
but you don't want to burn it down at
the same time.
How,
how beyond just making the case for it,
and I hadn't even heard of that
Singapore thing.
So now some new people are going to hear
about that concept.
How do you actually start making that
happen?
I mean,
is that you have to start doing it at
the local level.
I mean,
just get,
he knows probably that probably would
require a change at the national level
because you're talking about something
which would replace the way social
security is currently run.
They will switch social from a pay as
you go system to a fully funded system
of this,
this kind that would require action by
Congress or at the very least maybe by
state legislatures for some of the other
forms.
Um,
I think we just need to make the
political case written.
The difficulty of course is that you
have a whole bunch of people in the
existing system who can't simply be
switched over to the new one.
So you're going to have a period of
about 30 years,
certainly 20 years where there's an
overlap where you have the new system in
place and you have people who are,
uh,
under the old system.
That's inevitable.
It seems to me.
And that means in the short run,
this could be quite possibly,
but I think in the long run,
well worth doing.
Yeah.
Interesting.
So I heard you in a video that I saw you
do yesterday.
Talk about how,
how Libertarians are generally thought
of as not interventionists.
Yeah.
You think there,
although I don't think you prescribed to
it,
you think there is a situation where a
libertarian could be for some
intervention.
Basically the,
the for any kind of libertarian,
classical liberal,
the question with foreign policy is,
which course of action is going to most
maximize liberty both in the country
that is potentially doing the
intervening in this case the US for
example,
and the part of the world where the
intervention might take place.
Now.
That should be the guiding principle
behind what your foreign policy is.
Now,
what I would say,
and I agree with friend of mine,
Randy Barnett on this,
is he's been on the show.
There's nothing inherent or necessary
about libertarian principles that means
you must be a non interventionist.
What I would argue on they're here,
perhaps I disagree slightly with Randy,
is that,
uh,
the number of cases where the benefits
of liberty will be so great that you
would support intervention is actually
very,
very slight.
I would apply something like a just war
principle.
You have to show that really the benefit
is bound to exceed the cost,
uh,
and that the,
this is knowable and that the
intervention could be done in a way that
doesn't systematically violate human
rights.
So that's quite a high bar.
Yeah.
Wait,
let's pause there for a sec.
How much does the benefit have to be for
you and your society,
not just the people that you're
potentially doing?
Well,
I think it's more a matter of the cost
because if you think about intervention
in foreign parts of the world,
the,
one of the main arguments against that
from a libertarian or classical liberal
position is that it actually is bad for
liberty back home in the country doing
the intervening to the extent that the
United States becomes an empire and it
is an empire that's not pussy foot about
this.
That undermines republican institutions.
And Liberty back home,
and this is not a new phenomenon.
Many of the things that led to the
growth of the state in Great Britain
were because of British intervention
outside the rest of the world.
The India office,
which ran the Indian empire,
was our first big modern department of
States and then transformed the rest of
government by its example.
Same things.
You do these things over there,
wherever there is,
and then you actually need more state
power at well under that is provides an
example.
So in order to have,
for example,
you need to read large military if
you're going to have a kind of global
interventionist role that inevitably
does things like increase the role of
military domestically,
increases its purchasing power,
its clout,
builds up the military industrial
complex that Eisenhower warned against,
has all kinds of bad effects.
It also leads to growth of a
surveillance state.
It leads to the growth of the police
power of the state,
which we spoke about earlier,
which you might say is necessary in
certain cases,
but certainly not to the degree,
but he now.
And it just also generally gives our
rulers ideas above their station because
if you have the mindset that,
oh,
we can go over and be this benevolent
despot and transform the lives of these
people in other parts of the world,
this tends to naturally create a
mindset.
We think,
well,
there's these people here in our own
society they could do with our
benevolent interference as well.
And that's a very dangerous mindset.
Right.
And somehow we always have money to do
those adventures,
but we never had money to help what's
happening.
Yeah,
what a surprise.
Yeah.
What could be happening there,
you know,
it benefits all kinds of people that
mean.
The other quite shameful thing is that
this typically involves sending young
men from often poor backgrounds into
harms way when the children of the
people making these decisions are
certainly not joining the military.
And if they are,
they're probably not going to be sent
into harms way in that way,
which I think is seriously disreputable.
So I think I wouldn't rule out that
there are certain cases where an
intervention could be on balance,
beneficial for liberty both at home and
in the place where the intervention
takes place,
but I think that's vanishingly very low
probability.
There are very few cases like that in my
view.
Right.
So let's,
uh,
let's just take Syria for example,
because that's obviously the big one
that we know over 400,000
people are dead.
This thing is not ending anytime soon.
It's hard to know whose side we're on,
what's going on with Iran and Russia,
all of that stuff.
Now.
I think the main,
the mainstream libertarian think would
be even if we partly created this mess,
we just got to cut our losses and let it
be.
How do you,
how does ethics and morality get
involved as a classical liberal where
you see,
okay,
we don't want to be killing more people,
but maybe we could create humanitarian
corridors or maybe there's a way to do
some good there,
but it may not be cost effective for us.
The question is who are the actors in
this thing?
Because people always say,
okay,
we got to do something,
or what should we do?
Who is the we in this sentence now I
think people get two things confused and
conflated.
One is what should civil society do?
What should or can we do as individuals
and they're all kinds of things we can
do depending on what you think is the
right course of action,
but the other thing of course it means
is what should our government,
the government of United States,
the United Kingdom,
wherever do now in terms of what
governments should do.
Governments in this context are
basically the purveyors of deadly force,
which is that core function and so the
question therefore I think is slightly
different and really you want to
minimize harm.
It seems to me now I would argue that
actually the course of action that will
minimize harm in most cases is classic
foreign policy realism.
Because what you want to do is to
minimize the chances of war in large
scale conflict and I think actually
channeling bismarck is probably the way
to go.
Strange thing for liberals say,
but I do think in foreign policy,
asking yourself the question,
what would bismarck do is probably a
good way to go because foreign policy
rail is slight bismal do not generally
calls large scale walls.
Uh,
and that's what you want to do.
We'd be looking at what the government
should do.
You're looking to try and minimize the
amount of armed conflict that happened.
Sure.
So what do you,
what would bismarck do in a situation
that's already begun?
Oh,
it's too late for us now,
but is there,
is there a moral cost,
I guess is what my question is.
Is there a moral cost of knowing that
something horrible has happened
happening and that perhaps you could do
something again?
It's who's the,
you think it's this?
Yeah.
The question is,
is if you're saying there's something
terrible going on there,
I feel a kind of moral responsibility as
a human being for the suffering of my
fellow human beings in that part of the
world.
All kinds of things you can do,
you can give money to a non government
organization or a charity.
Some of that medicine.
So I'll prompt,
yeah,
you might even volunteer to work with
MSF as adoptive you're a doctor,
a paramedic,
you might support things like the
creation of a lobby.
The government in Syria,
the competent is to allow people to lead
noncoms civilian sullied the combat.
Don't cease fires you might argue for if
you.
On the other hand you might say,
well,
I think that this is the right side in
this conflict and if you feel strongly
about him,
pick up a gun and go and fight that.
That's the honest and vulnerable thing
to do or give money to help people
acquire mysteries and things of that.
Now the other hand,
the government is what you're talking
about.
My argument is that typically government
intervention,
military intervention by states in
conflicts of this kind is almost always
going to make the conflict more
intractable war,
bloody,
more extensive,
more long lasting,
and it's not going to be ultimately use
the interest even of the outside
parameters.
So much of this is driven by the desire
to avoid the other side getting on top.
And so you know the realist view there
as well.
Usually steer clear of it,
unless a vital national interest is at
stake.
You do not get involved because both on
pragmatic machiavellian grounds,
but also on moral grounds because if you
intervene,
this is very likely to make the whole
conflict worse than the otherwise would
be.
Syria.
I mean,
let me show this work.
In the case of Syria only predicted when
the Arab spring was going on that it
became serious.
It would be a bloodbath.
Now,
this didn't require great prescience
online.
My part,
because the whole point about Syria is
that the government is dominated by a
cleanse,
stroke,
religious sect.
The News Irys,
the Alawites is what asset comes from
who come from the mountain regional
Latakia virtually all of the other
people in Syria,
particularly the Sunni Orthodox,
Sunni Muslims,
regard them as rank heretics.
That means that a democratic regime in
Syria is probably not feasible at the
moment because if I sat on the alibis,
give up power.
You're dead.
Yeah,
and they're not so not going to do it.
So I knew there would be armed
resistance to any movement to have for
the state.
Now wants the civil ward started.
The question is what do you do?
The problem I think as far as western
policy goes,
is that a large part of western policy
has been to try and overthrow Asad,
but they have willed the end without
willing the means they've intervened,
but the intervention has actually been
of a kind that has simply made the
conflict more intractable and gone on
longer and it's provoked countervailing
intervention by the Iranians and the
Russians who for their own strategic
reasons,
don't want to see ever overthrown,
so that shows how government
intervention can actually make a
conflict that probably would have ended
one way or another.
I'm much more intractable.
My own view,
actually 40 it's worth is that the only
really effective way of resolving that
conflict is to partition Syria into
three or four states.
I think that's the only way to actually
do it.
Yeah.
I mean incredibly.
Joe Biden,
when he was running for president,
when he ended up being a Obama's bp at
eight years ago,
there was a moment in the debates where
he said,
we have to partition Syria and partition
Iraq and there should be an actual
Kurdish nation and this is the sooner
you should have an agent in the sheet
and all that,
and people laughed at him because it
sounded,
it sounded very academic and we're not
going to split these countries,
but at this point,
Syria is not really a nation state by
anybody.
That's a perfectly rational solution.
He was completed much about that.
Who looks at that part of the world and
it's a political realist is going to say
that partitioning several of these
states that were created totally
artificial.
Yeah.
By the British and the French during
World War II,
even on geographic lines,
really unreduced just lines in the sand
as the famous book calls it,
you know,
those states not viable.
They should really be broken up and
that's,
that would be a rational,
humane response to the situation
you now have.
Um,
I don't want to spend a ton of time with
this because we don't have that much
more time,
but how much,
how much of what's going on in the
Middle East is just because of the guys
that were drawing the map.
And if you look at a country like
Jordan,
it looks ridiculous.
The shape of Jordan is absurd.
It looks like a puzzle piece that got
mangled.
I mean,
how much is just that the people
actually drawing the map had nothing to
do with what was happening on the
ground.
By the way,
I don't blame you guys solely for that
because the Ottoman empire ran a lot of
it for a long time.
Actually.
What mean?
Seriously,
we,
you don't most terms what they will say
a pretty quickly is that things were
working a lot better.
They,
when they run it for you,
if,
if France Britain had followed the
ultimate anz and use the ultimate local
government units,
things might well have worked out better
because those units actually reflected
under underlying realities.
Many guises,
but know that that's part of the
problem.
Part of the problem in there as in large
areas of Africa is that you have
political units,
which do not make demographic sense,
but it's not just that I think there are
other factors as well.
There's been a collapse in the,
in the government,
in that huge area of the world,
central Africa,
up through the Middle East,
places like Libya for example.
What has happened is that the state,
the political order has collapsed and
what we're seeing is lots of violence
caused by nonstate actors,
basically clans,
gangs,
tribes,
terrorists groups.
We call them church people,
so we might as well call them criminal
gangs.
That's what they are basically,
and until some kind of stable political
order is recreated in that part of the
world,
I don't see that state of chaos ending
anytime soon.
The problem is that the existing
political order,
and this is where those guys sykes and
Pico come in,
is simply not sustainable because it's
based on an irrational thing.
The other thing that's going on there is
that basically you've had very,
very rapid population growth in that
part of the world in the last 30,
40 years.
Uh,
probably more than that region can
sustain ecologically and you have an
economy in large parts of that region,
which is a very badly run because it's
corrupting of incompetent government and
be as very dependent upon oil and what
you have now is lots and lots of
unemployed but overeducated young men
and that is always and everywhere.
A recipe for trouble.
Right?
It's fertile ground for terrorists.
Yeah.
Is there a little saving grace in that
because of the Internet now and that
information can spread so fast that
these people are learning.
There's other ways of life and that may
be that ultimately will be what allows
them to,
as they get older,
to create societies that'll be a little
more egalitarian.
Yes.
I think.
I think I am optimistic in the longer
term and the short term.
I'm a pessimist.
I'm afraid in the long run medium term,
I'm an optimist for that possible design
for most of the world because I do think
that things like that mean that the
world is going to become more
interconnected.
People are going to be more aware of
different ways of doing things too.
We're back to what we spoke about
earlier.
Uh,
they'll realize that their identity is
not something that they're stuck with,
that they can actually shape their own
life more,
but I think it's going to be awhile
before we get there,
my friend.
All right.
There's a whole slew of other things I
want to talk to you about to finish.
So we,
but we only have time for one of them.
Should we talk about drugs or is there
something that you want to really
discuss that you feel like we hit?
Whatever,
whatever you.
Whatever you want,
you know,
they are.
I always say a good interview is when I
don't look at the cards as well.
So we did it here.
All right.
So let's talk about drugs a little bit
because I think this is an interesting
place for the libertarian or classical
liberal.
You basically think that our war on
drugs,
it was completely ridiculous.
It's one of the worst policies ever.
Yeah.
Uh,
what would be a better policy related to
drugs?
I think there are two things to do.
The first thing is quite simply to
legalize drugs,
period across the board,
across the board.
What people do not realize is until the
18 nineties,
any drug was freely available.
If you were in a chemist in Great
Britain until 1922,
the United States until the age of 90
days,
you could go in,
you could order opm,
you could order morphine.
Arthur Conan doyle could go to the
chemist in London and get his weekly
supply of cocaine serious coke habit,
which is why Sherlock Holmes has a coke
habits in the stories,
so this regime we now have as being
created peace mail since the 19 twenties
basically,
so it's not inevitable.
It's a specific policy response and the
results would have been catastrophic.
It has led to incredibly high rates of
incarceration here in the United States,
which means countless lives ruined and
severely damaged if not destroyed.
It means it's given enormous amounts of
money to some seriously evil and
unpleasant people and led to the growth
of an enormous network of international
organized crime,
which would not otherwise exist.
In terms of geopolitics,
this is one of the major ways terrorist
organizations get money.
It's a catastrophe in terms of that.
It's undermine the stability of large
parts of the world.
Like Columbia for example.
Increasingly that's one of the reasons
why Venezuela was in bad shape quite
apart from the incompetence of the
government of Mexico.
We all know there's like a war going on
in some parts of Mexico.
Them,
okay,
so this is an altar and it hasn't even
done the thing is meant to do,
which is reduce the use of drugs.
In fact,
actually this has gone up.
Not only that,
but an inevitable result of this policy
is that the suppliers and the users both
go for harder drugs because he wants to
get more bang for the buck.
You want also to sell and to use
products that are less bulky,
easier to conceal.
Same thing has happened with prohibition
during the 19 twenties were the
Americans went from being a beer
drinking nation to being a hard liquor
drinking nation,
which is not what you want and what you
want to do is control alcohol trick.
So I would say that this,
in terms of its own goals,
this is a catastrophic policy failure.
Now,
having said that,
I'm not one of these people who is
channeling Timothy O'leary and thinks
that drugs are good for you.
There's no doubt there is a problem with
widespread use of drugs.
It's worth saying,
by the way,
that the real problem anyway,
not least here in the United States,
is the massive increase in the use of
prescription drugs.
The number of people who are psycho
truck,
big mood altering drugs is staggering
and it has grown dramatically since the
1966.
So there's a more general problem of
drug use in advanced countries,
particularly North America,
of which illegal drug use is a subset.
Now that,
am I mistaken?
Are you guys in Britain?
You don't have the commercials we have,
right?
Are They not legal there?
We get every commercial on every,
especially on cable news for all of the
prescriptions.
It doesn't,
that's all out now.
That's best.
That's not allowed under the,
uh,
you know,
advertising regulations in the United
Kingdom.
That might be a regulation I'd before.
It is strange when you're watching
television in the United States to think
just everyone this country suffer from
in large.
Yeah.
You got that on a cartoon,
a cloud following you.
Anyways,
so
the thing is,
what I think is that what you need to do
is to have a social movement to address
the undoubted real problems with the
drug trade in which you could do.
If the government got out of this and my
model would be temperance were in the
19th century at the start of the 19th
century,
on both sides of the Atlantic.
Pretty much everyone was in a drunken
stupor most of the time.
The amount of drinking was nominal and
binding.
18,
eighties and nineties.
Most prediction,
the great majority of Americans have
become seriously sober.
People who maybe drink very
occasionally,
they're not heavy drinkers the way their
grandparents had been.
That is not due to government.
It's due to the enormous social movement
of temperance,
which unfortunately also wanted to use
the law to stop the residual temp
central and drinking.
Even think about smoking.
Okay.
I'm not keen on all the antismoking laws
we have,
but on the other hand there's been a
huge change in social attitudes to
smoking,
just made socially,
just not the thing to do to smoking
company.
That's the way to address the underlying
problem that we have with drugs.
It's through social actual bank kind of
war on drugs is actually making that
kind of effective social action less
likely and causing a ton of other
problems.
Right.
Is the smoking one must be a tough one
for you though because on one hand at
least here our taxes are incredibly high
and smoking,
so this is a government so they sort of
tried to price it out of the market,
which I guess you wouldn't really well
or I don't think the ultra price sound
market quite more.
They're trying to maximize their
revenue,
which is something different because our
theory of these taxes is they're meant
to stop.
You and I are buying cigarettes,
but actually I don't like the US
government.
The British government would have a
panic fits if people stop smoking
because they get 7 billion pounds a year
of revenue from smoking taxes.
Right.
So in a weird way,
they need it.
Exactly.
Plus also,
um,
they really ought to encourage people to
smoke because if you smoke you're likely
to die younger.
You won't be claiming a whole bunch of
healthcare benefits.
But no,
the point about that is that that is
actually a very bad policy because the
demand for cigarettes and tobacco
products is highly inelastic.
And so what you're doing actually is
hurting the poor more than anybody else.
There are other ways of doing it.
Like I said,
social pressure.
Yeah.
So what about for the person?
So I'm pretty much with you on the
philosophical part of how the government
should deal with this and the,
and the actual tangible part of drugs.
I would have some concern if they just
say if,
if heroin was lead with legal tomorrow
and,
and kids could just get it at a border.
So you look,
we're here in La,
there are pot stores on every corner.
I have a law license for it.
So I'm not doing something illegal,
but what,
what do you do for the real.
I'm not even talking about the Timothy
leary mushroom stuff,
you know,
I would have met them really addictive
stuff.
Well actually meet some of the drugs
that are on.
I'd be much more worried about things
like sedatives or cocaine.
The level would be heroin actually.
Interesting.
But that's another matter.
Um,
the thing is to say that drugs should be
sold legally,
does not mean that to be a complete free
for all a,
they would clearly be regulations,
for example,
saying that people cannot buy them below
a certain age just as we have with
alcohol and tobacco for good reason.
Because you,
you'd think that somebody under a
certain age,
which you set arbitrarily,
it does not have the judgment to know
whether or not they should do this.
And you should enforce laws on that
very,
very strictly and very,
very firmly.
You might well have a system where
certain categories of drugs or
substances,
you basically say,
well,
uh,
you could do with the Swedish government
tried alcohol and have a rationing
system.
There are various ways around that.
The point is it wouldn't be just a case
of,
oh,
you can walk into any store and just
buying your your shots of morphine and
heroin over the counter,
like almost certainly there'll be a
whole array of a legislation.
The point is it will be sold by a legal
retailer who would have strong
incentives to have high quality product,
not to sell it to people who are going
to be problematic in one way or another
because they would have a vicarious
liability under the law,
for example,
and unlike the situation,
the where that being sold by seriously
dodgy people,
criminals of the worst kind who actually
have an incentive to not care about who
they sell it to sell it.
So actually if you're concerned about
protecting vulnerable people,
which is what we're talking about here.
Yeah.
Then actually making the sale of this
substance legal is the way to go because
it means that you're much more likely to
be able to look out for their interests
and the sellers are much less likely to
have an incentive to screw them over,
to be blunt.
Right.
And interestingly,
it gets back to sort of what's been the
through line here,
which is that a little government
involvement in a certain way.
It could be.
Okay.
So I almost think,
I almost think that my new phrase now
when people say classical,
what's a classical liberal?
I almost think it's a realistic
libertarian.
Do you think
that's a good way of putting it?
Yes,
absolutely.
And I mean the thing is say very often
limited government and small limited
government even more so is a lot more
effective at achieving the ends that big
government liberals wanted to have.
The big government is very good than
here.
I think that's a perfect way to end
this.
It's been a pleasure.
I didn't look down lines.
That's how I know it's a good one.
Uh,
for more.
I Dr Steve Davies,
you can check out learn
liberty.org/speakers/Steve
Dash Davies.
Thanks for watching.
We'll do it again next week.